[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
bienvenidos escala en París una emisión
de radio Francia internacional y France
24 en español en la que cada semana
damos la palabra artistas a gente del
mundo de la ciencias de las artes de la
cultura de los deportes la política y
claro Está también de la sociedad civil
más de 100.000 franceses viven en el
subcontinente americano entendido esto
desde México hasta la tierra del fuego
pasando por el Caribe de acuerdo con
datos del gobierno francés a partir del
2010 esta población está representada en
la asamblea nacional francesa es decir
el equivalente de la cámara de diputados
en la segunda circunscripción de los
franceses establecidos fuera de Francia
hoy recibimos aquí en escala en París a
la representante de esa circunscripción
la diputada eleonor Kawaii miembro de
Renacimiento la formación política del
presidente Emmanuel macrón bienvenida a
esta escala en París Muchas gracias
muchas gracias Un placer tenerla con
nosotros usted fue elegida a diputada de
esa segunda circunscripción tras las
elecciones legislativas de de junio
pasado es la primera vez que se
presentaba como diputada es usted de
origen francés y con ciertos dijéramos
orígenes también en República Dominicana
ya hecho su primer viaje inmediatamente
hacia América Latina el primero fue en
agosto pasado a la toma de posición del
presidente Gustavo Petro después en
septiembre ha viajado también a otros
países de América del Sur qué es lo que
le están pidiendo los ciudadanos
franceses A usted como representante de
esa segunda circunscripción Bueno muy
buenas muy buenos días Muchas gracias
por recibirme y muchas gracias por
hablar de América Latina y de los
intereses de los franceses que reciben
allá Gracias son mucho más de 100.000
franceses Esos son los que están
inscritos en el registro y que votan en
realidad son centenas de miles de
franceses que viven allá La mayoría son
binacionales se estima que más o menos
los dos tercios de los residentes
franceses en el Continente
latinoamericano son binacionales Y
hispanófonos entonces de verdad tiene
muchas esperas de la parte de esa
población de que se hable de ellos de
que se tome en cuenta sus
especificidades y su especificidad
también como latinoamericanos Entonces
está muy pendiente de lo que pasa a
nivel político en sus diferentes países
pero también de mantener un vínculo
fuerte con Francia ya sea por la
educación de sus hijos con la red de
escuelas francesas de la O también con
mantener un vínculo con las embajadas y
los consulados todas esas son pedidos
que son recurrentes y luego hay pedidos
específicos en función de los países
como decía yo soy Franco dominicano O
sea que yo también soy binacional crecí
en República Dominicana en una comunidad
francesa O sea que me identifico
plenamente con lo que puede esperar un
francés de América Latina hay que saber
que de acuerdo con el sistema electoral
francés Hay 11 circunscripciones de
franceses que viven en el exterior en la
circunscripción de la diputada kaguá hay
nada menos ni nada más que 33 estados
que usted tiene que de la población
francesa que vive en ellos desde México
decíamos hasta Tierra de Fuego y el
Caribe hay uno de esos estados de su
circunscripción y leonokawa que desde
hace varios meses vive una profunda
crisis política Social es Haití de
acuerdo con cifras oficiales viven ahí
aproximadamente un poco más de 2.000
franceses seguramente Habrá más eh bien
qué le piden como diputada Qué puede
hacer por ellos ante una situación tan
crítica como la que se vive hoy en Haití
es muy importante hablar de Haití y yo
creo que el hecho de que hablemos de
Haití hoy es fundamental todo el mundo
sabe que hay una crisis política social
económica y ahora mismo también de
seguridad extrema en Haití como no se ha
visto nunca sanitaria también yo como le
decía crecía en República Dominicana muy
cercana Haití No solo geográficamente
pero también con vínculos históricos y
siempre estaba muy pendiente Yo creo que
lo que está pasando hoy en Haití nunca
se ha visto y lo primero que podemos
hacer nosotros los representantes pero
también los medias todo el mundo
estoy hablando de Haití siempre yo eso
lo hago desde que fui él elegida
he hecho en mi primer derecho pedido
político fue que se me respondiera sobre
la situación del Liceo francés en Haití
que está ahora mismo en una situación de
virtualidad desde hace más de un año no
se puede abrir por temas seguridad pero
yo de seguridad pero yo estoy
manteniendo un vínculo casi digamos En
todo caso semanal con las autoridades
con la embajada con el Ministerio para
ver cómo puede evolucionar la situación
luego la ayuda humanitaria la ayuda
también que se está haciendo a nivel de
las instituciones y también retomar el
diálogo entre los países Porque hoy hay
una crisis también institucional muy
fuerte en Haití usted declaró que los
franceses que viven en América Latina
lacito deben saber que sus
preocupaciones sus expectativas con
respecto a los países a sus países son
escuchadas y descritas narradas en la
asamblea nacional francesa Pero cuál es
la reacción de la asamblea nacional
francesa hasta ahora yo no he visto
ninguna iniciativa de ley que haya sido
en la nueva legislatura respecto a esos
franceses que viven en América Latina en
este caso Bueno ahí hay dos temas ahí el
tema de los franceses en el extranjero Y
el tema de los franceses del América
Latina y de la importancia de América
Latina sobre los franceses en el
extranjero como lo decía ustedes somos
11 diputados y llevamos de manera
conjunta y además fuera de los partidos
Aunque la mayoría somos de Renacimiento
de Johnny songs de manera tostada
estamos proponiendo una serie de leyes
de legislaciones de enmiendas a leyes
por ejemplo de de de la fiscalidad del
delfines para tomar en cuenta la
situación particular de los franceses en
el extranjero Y yo estoy haciendo un
esfuerzo muy grande de pedagogía con
otros de mis colegas porque
desgraciadamente mucho de los colegas de
franceses que reciben en Francia Ven a
los franceses A los franceses del
extranjero como exiliado Fiscales y eso
De verdad que no tiene nada que ver con
la realidad Entonces el trabajo de
pedagogía es muy importante después
sobre América Latina Yo soy
vicepresidenta de la comisión de asuntos
externos a más tarde y yo desde que fui
electa hace cinco meses no hay una
intervención y e intervenciones
semanales que haga sin que hable de
América Latina ayer justo interrogué al
gobierno sobre la relación con Brasil
que va a cambiar seguramente luego de
las elecciones y también al ministro
Olivier
y le ofrecen los extranjeros sobre sobre
América Latina O sea que de verdad que
estoy haciendo ese trabajo también para
que América Latina vuelva a hacer un
foco en la asamblea nacional pues
justamente usted me abre la puerta para
la siguiente pregunta no ha de ser muy
sencillo su trabajo sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta yo lo digo el marcado
desinterés del presidente Emmanuel Macro
por la región quiero decir que es el
primer presidente desde la época del
presidente y scarleston en los años 70
que durante su primeros mandato no ha
hecho un solo viaje oficial a América
Latina hay que recordar que hay 570
millones de habitantes en esa región
como explica usted esta falta
yo evidentemente hice la misma
me dijo exactamente la misma pregunta y
tuve la misma inquietud sobre todo
cuando decidí presentarme como candidata
para ese partido sin embargo lo que hay
que saber es que no hay un desinterés o
una falta de reconocimiento de la
importancia de América Latina sino una
circunstancias que hicieron que durante
el primer quinquenio incluida la crisis
sanitaria hicieron que no se dio ese
viaje pero lo que sí le puedo afirmar es
que hay una voluntad y en todo caso hay
una diputada ahí poniendo presión para
que América Latina vuelva a ser un
centro y hay una agenda presidencial de
viajes de hecho Emmanuel fue el primer
uno de los primeros presidentes en
Llamar a Lula cuando fue electo ahora va
a recibir al presidente Gustavo Petro
para el Foro de la paz también está
jugando un rol importante en el proceso
de Camino hacia la democracia de
Venezuela Yo creo que si bien no hubo lo
suficiente ni muchísimo menos en el
primer quinquenio ahora y más con esta
diputada que tiene va a haber un interés
importante no sólo del parlamento que
solo lo puedo garantizar pero también
del ejecutivo francés porque ciertamente
durante su primer quinquenio él recibió
efectivamente el presidente macri de
Argentina recibió el presidente Duque de
Colombia recibió el presidente piñeira
de Chile pero efectivamente hechos y las
señales son muy fuertes en diplomacia le
digo no hubo un solo viaje oficial hubo
un viaje de menos de dos horas de Buenos
Aires con motivo del g-20 pero fuera de
su madre pero qué bueno que esté usted
como diputada justamente Leonor la presa
mundial y hablando del interés de
Francia por la América Latina ha dado
mucha repercusión al apretón de manos
que se dieron en El Cairo el presidente
Emmanuel macrón y el presidente de
Venezuela maduro Nicolás Maduro esto
quiere decir que la posición del
gobierno francés ha cambiado respecto al
presidente al mandatario venezolano lo
llamó presidente cuando que antes lo
había desconocido con nunca lo reconoció
Mejor dicho cómo me explica esta
situación Bueno yo no soy evidentemente
portavoz de el gobierno francés Entonces
no me puedo pronunciar sobre la posición
oficial del Saluda a la iniciativa pero
yo pienso realmente la manera mi
interpretación de este de este gesto
simbólico muy fuerte Como usted bien lo
dijo Es que hay una voluntad de Francia
de jugar un papel importante en hacer
que Venezuela llegue a la democracia que
se celebra en elecciones que la
oposición y que el gobierno puedan
sentarse en una mesa de hecho el
gobierno francés está apoyando el
proceso de México y está recibiendo
venezolana y el régimen de maduras
exactamente y está justamente
incentivando esas negociaciones al
recibir aquí en París mañana mismo o
pasado mañana para ser preciso a los a
los diferentes partidos de oposición y y
de gobierno venezolano Entonces yo lo
veo más bien como un alentamiento y no
como un reconocimiento
de la acción de maduro ni muchísimo
menos porque no vamos a cambiar de un
día para otro una posición que fue muy
firme muy clara Pero más bien una
apertura porque el contexto es diferente
porque la única manera de llegar a la
Paz es hablando con contrincantes
Sigamos hablando de lo que sucede en su
circunscripción diputada de Leonor kaguá
Usted lo sabe perfectamente y lo decía
el presidente Lula da Silva ha sido
reelecto en las elecciones a finales de
octubre con la posición de su cargo el
primero de enero se da por hecho que con
eso muy probablemente en los meses a
venir el acuerdo comercial que se firmó
entre la Unión Europea y Brasil el
mercosur se apruebe definitivamente fue
aprobado en 2019 de manera general falta
la ratificación de cada estado en este
caso Francia sin duda alguna se va a ser
más tarde que temprano pero mi pregunta
es una estamos hablando de cambio
ecológico ese acuerdo comercial implica
que cada año vendrán desde brás desde el
mercosur a Europa 200 mil doscientas mil
toneladas de carne
miles de millones de cereales dado el
cambio climático del que estamos
hablando Cómo se puede luchar
efectivamente contra ese cambio
climático con una situación de estas es
necesario ratificar ese acuerdo
comercial
para mí es fundamental la cuestión es
cómo alimentamos al planeta y al mismo
tiempo preservamos la biodiversidad y
nuestros ecosistemas de hecho por eso
pedí que me dieran una misión en la
asamblea nacional en la en la comisión
de asuntos externos para analizar
justamente este tema a nivel
internacional porque creo que es un tema
que no se puede analizar de manera local
o nacional entonces sobre el acuerdo del
mercosur yo creo que hay que repensarlo
y de hecho por eso el proceso que estaba
ya bien avanzado fue parado por Francia
en particular porque no estamos para
tener deforestación importada o sea
justamente francés tiene una posición
muy clara de que no va a aceptar
productos que vengan de deforestación lo
que hay que entender es Cómo se puede
producir y alimentar y al mismo tiempo
preservar y en ese sentido hay muchas
iniciativas extremadamente interesantes
que yo creo que hay que desarrollar por
ejemplo la fd la agencia francesa de
desarrollo sostiene en América Latina
varios proyectos de policultura dentro
de la del Bosque amazónico que están
dando un ejemplo de cómo se puede
combinar cierto a una escala todavía
pequeña Pero eso se pudiera extender
Entonces todos esos proyectos yo lo fui
a visitar en Ecuador en Perú y ahora
tengo también la el honor de ser miembro
del Consejo administrativo de la fd y en
ese sentido también estoy siguiendo esos
temas de manera muy muy muy muy digamos
detallada y con mucho interés Pues nos
mantendremos al tanto del trabajo que
usted realiza como representante de esta
segunda circunscripción de los franceses
establecidos en el exterior en el
exterior eleonor kaguá Muchas gracias
por habernos acompañado en esta escala
en París a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita la próxima semana aquí en otra
escala en París
[Música]